Let's go next to our caller from the three
one five area code.
Who's calling today from three one five?
Oh, my own.
Yes, you are.
Who's this?
Hi, I'm still fullfil, what's up?
For some color, I was just thinking about
how all this is going to impact the election
and impact just politics going forward to
the rest of the year and beyond.
I mean, the core protests of the pandemic,
you know, I would want to believe this is
going to really be a one two punch to Trump
to the Republicans.
But I have been concerned about a backlash
coming.
And as well as I think even if Republicans
are taken out and Trump's taken out in the
election, that they tend to do better as an
opposition and they tend to do better campaigning
and having something to have someone to run
against.
And so I just wonder if any any good can be
made for this.
If we can get your Democrats and progressives
into positions of power to affect change,
that it's not going to lead to kind of a similar
backlash, just like after Obama and Democrats
came in after Bush.
And so, listen, there's a lot of questions
in there.
Let's address at least a couple of the things
you're mentioning.
First of all, the of of course, Republicans
are going to take whoever is ever in power
on the Democratic side, demonize them, fundraised
by lying about them, come up with the most
horrible allegations and a sort of, oh, of
course, that's going to happen.
If we say, well, then we'd better not elect
anybody, then we're just gonna lose every
election.
So, of course, they're going to do it.
We need to be better, better at fighting them
rather than ceding the space and conceding
that to them.
Your first question was, could there be a
backlash and Trump rockets to reelection in
November?
I think the answer is yes.
And this is why I've been urging such caution.
You know, right now we've got a disastrous
economic situation partially fueled by a disastrous
reaction by Trump to the pandemic.
Combined with Trump saying, hey, let's here's
the solution to protests about police brutality.
Let's send in the federal military to be even
more brutal like it's crazy.
Joe Biden is up eleven in some polls, OK?
I think it is you're very right to be skeptical
that this is going to hold through November.
If the protests die down, it's very unlikely
the protests are going to last five months.
If Corona virus continues to decline in a
lot of places, I mean, it's going up in some
places and it's very much down in some places.
But if the economy starts to appear to be
recovering, you could get a window of six
weeks in late October into November where
Trump gets himself reelected because people
feel like, hey, things are getting back on
track.
And so I think we need to be very careful
about looking at any of these polls that say,
oh, Biden is going to crush him.
Biden may crush Trump.
Biden may lose.
And we've got to be really careful about it.
Right.
And obviously, I I've never been the type
of person that felt like you shouldn't vote
even if your candidate won the primary.
Yeah.
And also that I do believe that Trump does
have a chance of winning, although, again,
I want to I want to believe me, I'm not going
to let myself be lulled into a false insecurity.
I do want to believe that he's on his way
out.
I think I'm just very scarred from things
like Kim Vete politically, really when Obama
or during Obama's first election.
And that's when I like my my beliefs.
You have to become solidified.
And I think just the backlash to him, how
swift it was.
I mean, I remember it was drought when the
Tea Party first cropped up.
It was between early in February, April 2009.
I mean, if I recall correctly, it was very
soon, very soon after he came in.
And then into 2000 and 2010 midterms.
I just think that's that's something, too.
I mean, I'm probably getting ahead of myself.
Well, yeah.
Listen, Phil, I here's what we got to do.
Let's try to replace Trump with Biden.
Let's try to take control of the Senate.
We've got five, six good, good races that
could be won and then OK.
The opposition party tends to win in midterms,
but maybe this time they don't.
And then we fight for the 2022 midterms.
We can't win the 2022 midterms this November.
We can only win the elections that are this
November, this November, if that makes sense.
All right, my friend, I'm going to let you
go because I've got a bunch of people who
want to get on.
Let me take a quick break.
If you're holding.
Don't hang up because we will get right back
to the phones momentarily.